[Musik]
seit wochen führt der russische
präsident wladimir putin einen groß
angelegten krieg gegen die ukraine sein
ziel die besetzung des gesamten landes
und der schnelle sturz der regierung
bild zeigt was vor ort passiert erklärt
angriffs und verteidigungsstrategien und
liefert mit animationen grafiken und
expertengesprächen wichtige hintergründe
am 24 februar schaut die welt
fassungslos richtung ukraine
es herrscht krieg im land russland
beginnt mit ersten angriffen aus der
luft putins truppen wollen die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew in kürzester
zeit einnehmen
julian hat uns videos mitgebracht die
einen hubschrauber angriff zeigen auf
den wir direkt mal schauen können wie
man ihn so in europa wenn überhaupt
schon mal eigentlich noch nie gesehen
hat julian was wir sehen ist ein angriff
von russischen kampfhubschraubern und
auch luft lande operation
der hatte ich eben gerade ereignet und
zwar nicht irgendwo sondern ganz in der
nähe der ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
dort sind offenbar von belarus aus
mindestens 20 helikopter der russischen
luftwaffe
eingedrungen in den ruhe in den
ukrainischen luftraum und sind dann bis
kurz vor die hauptstadt geflogen unter
den hubschrauber truppen
transporthubschrauber die sehen wir hier
ganz vorne links beispielsweise das sind
so genannte mi-8-hubschrauber was wir
sehen dass tatsächlich eine ja also aus
möchte aus dem lehrbuch eine luft lande
operation hier ist in der stadt rostow
mal 16 kilometer nordwestlich vom kiew
eine landung gerade geplant und die hat
auch funktioniert wie wir mittlerweile
wissen in rostock gibt es einen
militärflugplatz und dieser flugplatz
ist sehr sehr wichtig für die russischen
truppen weil er ihn sozusagen ein
sprungbrett nach kiew liefert wir sehen
russische kampfhubschrauber und
transporthubschrauber die mit raketen
auf diesen stützpunkt schießen um ihn
kurz danach einzunehmen mit dann
tatsächlich auch soldaten die aus dem
hubschrauber heraus springen ganz genau
also wir sehen schüsse in verschiedene
richtungen gehören auch das meer
maschinengewehrfeuer der der
hubschrauber was wir gesehen dass größe
dieses spritzten in alle richtungen von
diesen lichteffekten dort das ist er
gegen luftabwehr raketen gerichtet das
sind die sogenannten flair gibt es auch
bei westlichen hubschraubern die ihnen
genommen werden damit man nicht
getroffen wird wir wissen aber
mittlerweile dass einer der hubschrauber
abgeschossen wurde von der ukrainischen
armee das heißt die ukraine die
versuchen natürlich in stützpunkt zu
verteidigen schießen mit boden luft
waffen auf diese hubschrauber aber die
waren am ende in der überzahl oder
übermächtig und konnte neben mit den
raketen die wir da gerade auch sehen
diesen stützpunkt einnehmen hier ist die
stadt und hier ist er der flughafen
quasi noch der grössere teil wie
entfernung nach hier sind sind auch zum
gibt verschiedene militärflughäfen auch
in kiew die waren wohl den russen noch
zu gut
beschützt das sind tatsächlich 16
kilometer also mit anderen worten man
hat jetzt hier einen brückenkopf
brückenkopf bedeutet eben man hat ein
ort eingenommen und dorthin kann jetzt
nachschub fließen können weitere
hubschrauber personen bringen soldaten
bringen die dann zb von hier aus sich in
die vororte von kiew vor kämpfen könnten
es soll ein blitzkrieg werden die
russische armee dringt von norden und
von süden in weitere ukrainische stadt
gebiete vor
also dieser krieg läuft etwa 24 stunden
und bereits jetzt sozusagen findet er an
den toren der hauptstadt statt das kann
man so sagen gestern hatten wir diese
dramatische situation dass ein flugfeld
16 kilometer von der hauptstadt
eingenommen wurde so saß zumindest
damals aus das wäre dann der brückenkopf
gewesen über an dem mann verstärkung
hätte bringen können russische
verstärkungen in die hauptstadt was
müssen wir da über die situation wir
haben auch den hubschrauber
eingezeichnet wie ist da an diesem
flugfeld die lage die lage ist
unübersichtlich aber es deutet viel
darauf hin dass sie
brutalstmöglich für die ukrainer ist die
ukraine haben mehrmals erklärt dass sie
den flughafen angreifen dass sie
versuchen ihn zurückzuerobern es gibt
aber keine mehr davon viel schlimmer ist
dass der russische generalstab etwa vor
zwei stunden mitgeteilt hat dass man
diesen brückenkopf mittlerweile mit
seiner haupt macht erreicht hat der
ukrainische generalstab hat nachmittag
gemeldet dass die truppen noch etwa 30
kilometer von kiew entfernt werden auch
das wäre schon eine katastrophe weil das
bedeuten würde dass alles nördlich davon
50 kilometer schon eingenommen wurden
durch die russen man hat heute
nachmittag brücken gesprengt man hat
also die brücke nördlich von kiew
gesprengt und das ist schon eine
verzweiflungstat er immer warum springt
man brücken ja also wenn wenn eine armee
die eine stadt verteidigt anfängt die
brücken außen rum zu sprengen dann denkt
man nur noch als bloß überlegen
vorsichtig gesagt also man möchte auf
jeden fall dass der gegner nicht darüber
kann dass er mit seinen panzern erstmal
außen rum fahren muss oder sogar eine
behelfsbrücke aufbauen muss aber man
muss sich das vorstellen dass es schief
da war noch bis vor zwei tagen frieden
und tausende mussten über diese brücken
über große autobahnbrücken sind das die
hat man heute gesprengt das heißt man
geht tatsächlich von dem
allerschlimmsten aus und wir haben
gestern auch diese verschiedenen vorstoß
gehabt hier ein hier ein hier ein wir
wissen heute dass die alle miteinander
vereint sind es gibt nur noch eine front
ist die ukraine hält nichts mehr von
ihrer eigenen grenze zu russland und wir
wissen dass die großstadt sumi die erste
ist die gestern eingenommen wurde zu
mieten ist 260.000 100 viertelmillion
einwohner wurde gestern eingenommen in
prag wird noch gekämpft hat man noch
nicht erobert im süden sind die russen
weiter vorgestoßen richtung von der krim
aus erst gestern nach noten und dann
heute weiter nach osten nämlich richtung
don was man will unbedingt diese
landbrücke haben man möchte die
miteinander vereint und da wurde heute
nachmittag die stadt milito pohl 160
tausend einwohner eingenommen die ist
etwa hier auch da gibt es noch kämpfe
aber die stadt wurde erstmal eingenommen
und dass das ist unfassbar für die
ukraine
die ukraine wehren sich mit kräften
gegen den russischen aggressor sie
verteidigen ihr land aus der luft die
russischen boden truppen besetzen die
hafenstadt milito polen
wir haben bilder aus dieser stadt wo man
eben sieht wie das dann aussieht wenn
eben die zivilbevölkerung aus dem
fenster guckt und dann sieht man
plötzlich oh mann da laufen russische
soldaten durch meine stadt durch meine
straße ein größerer konvoi eine größere
patrouille von eben russischen soldaten
die hier patroullieren auf der straße
während das bedeutet diese markierung
hier die wir die wir da immer wieder
sehen auf den fahrzeugen genau dieses
zeit also als taktisches zeichen
sozusagen es zum einen
wahrscheinlich zur freund feind
unterscheidung üblicherweise haben ja
wir sehen ja da zwei streitkräfte
aufeinandertreffen die ukrainische und
russische armee die in vielen
waffensystemen ähnliche waffensystemen
aus als wären die gleichen sachen
systeme besitzen das jetzt zum beispiel
ein russischer konvoi am straßenrand der
für große zerstörung spricht und dafür
eben spricht dass die russen und die
russischen streitkräfte am ende nicht so
durch das land kommt vordringen können
wie das virus selbst gedacht und geplant
haben und die tatsache dass dann so
solch riesiger konvoi erschossen wurde
also mutmaßlich
sieht alles danach aus dass ein
luftangriff wahrscheinlich ukrainische
erdkampfflugzeuge es 25 das spricht
dafür dass die dass die russische
streitkräfte immer noch nicht
ansatzweise lufthoheit haben und ist aus
russischer sicht natürlich ein absoluter
albtraum denn dass ein eigener konvoi
mit so vielen fahrzeugen wir sehen ja
auch viele logistik fahrzeuge am anfang
sind wahrscheinlich franken brückenbauer
also alles logistik die man braucht um
weiter vorzukommen im land so
aufgerieben so zerstört wird schutzlos
ausgeliefert ist da offenbar der
ukrainischen luftwaffe das spricht dann
doch dafür dass da ganz viel auch auf
taktischer ebene womöglich noch nicht so
funktioniert wie sich das selbst erhofft
haben
seit fünf tagen tobt der krieg die
ukrainische armee attackiert intensiver
aus der luft eine drohne zerstört einen
russischen militärkonvoi bild erklärt
die waffe der ukraine hierbei handelt es
sich um eine bayraktar drohne aus
türkischer produktion
die wir auch schon über syrien sehr
aktiv die war im armenien aserbaidschan
krieg sehr aktiv und wir sehen jetzt
gleich was hier in alle richtung geht
das sind also raketen das ist munition
wie hier explodiert sondern barak
patrone die hat ja die also sondern
sieht explosion kann ein auto zerstören
oder kann ein fahrerhaus von einem lkw
zerstören aber das was wir sehen das
zerstört alles außen rum da ist nicht
die drohne sondern das ist die munition
die hier getroffen produktion vielleicht
auch kerosin benzin die wälder weise du
hast die drohne angesprochen wir wollen
einmal weil viele leute ja keine
vorstellung haben so sieht sie aus die
drohne und eben bewaffnet hier mit
diesen
raketen die dann auf bodenziele
abgefeuert werden können du hast gesagt
türkische drohne wir sehen es auch hier
also aus türkische hersteller wie kommt
die in die hand der ukraine türkei hat
etwa vor zwei jahren den vertrag
abgeschlossen über die bayraktar
sozusagen der mann möchte die
exportschlager der türken auch der
aserbaidschaner viel davon gekauft und
im krieg in armenien die sehr
erfolgreich eingesetzt
mittlerweile sind ungefähr 25 dieser
drohnen in der ukraine und ein weiterer
punkt der uns auch davor erschaudern
lässt wie unglaublich schlecht punkte in
diesem krieg geplant hat ist dass die
überhaupt noch abheben könnten die
brauchen ja die brauchen startplatz die
brauchen eine startbahn und landebahn
die können nicht von irgend ein
waldstück abheben sondern wir brauchen
wirklich eine startbahn und die können
offenbar immer noch abheben das ist
genau das wonach richtig warm wollte am
ersten tag da standen wir haben darüber
gesprochen wie gezielt putin die
luftfeder der ukraine bombardiert aber
es scheint ihnen eben nicht gelungen zu
sein alle dieser flugfelder aus zu
auszuschalten denn diese drohnen können
weiter starten sie starten aus
ukrainischen hoheitsgebiet die kommen
nicht aus der türkei oder sowas um das
einmal klar zu machen die ukraine haben
diese drohen gekauft und steuern sie
selbst aber der krieg der läuft nicht
nur in der luft sondern er läuft auch am
boden und das tier das wollen wir ihnen
zeigen denn das zeigt wie mutig die
ukraine am boden wirklich kämpfen und
wie erfolgreich sie auch kämpfen wir
sehen jetzt hier gleich auf der linken
seite da sehen wir ihnen einen ich mag
ihn mal in gelb passend zur ukrainischen
farbe da steht er einen ukrainischen
soldaten und dr der hard geschultert
eine anti panzer rakete und dann julian
erklären was passiert danach ja genau
also dass er nur kann ich das soldat der
am rand einer straße steht und mit einer
sogenannten ende einer britischen anti
panzer rakete schießt von dna hat die
ukraine etwa 1.000 2.000 stück gespendet
bekommen vor dem krieg in den letzten
wochen vor dem krieg und das andere soll
ich bin nicht ganz sicher was soll ein
t90 aber sein dass einer der modernsten
kampfpanzer den den russland hat
der ort von der seite getroffen an der
seite ist die panzerung nicht so stark
wie wie vorne und insofern ist es
absichtlich natürlich das sozusagen als
90 grad dort geschossen wollte da ist ja
noch intakter ferner durch dieses dorf
und er sieht wahrscheinlich nicht dass
hier von links eben die gleich sozialen
diese ukrainische rakete ihnen treffen
wird genau ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
also wahrscheinlich sind noch soldaten
drinnen sieht der fährt gerade nicht
sondern die beiden stehen da am
straßenrand unter umständen wurden die
vollgestopft und ist das benzin
ausgegangen haben wir bei hunderten
russischen fahrzeugen erlebten ist
einfach das benzin ausgegangen
irgendwann die soldaten verschanzen sich
dann da drinnen wollen nicht rauskommen
und dementsprechend haben sie ein großes
problem julian abschließend die aktuelle
lage in der ukraine dass hier das war
tag 1 etwa die ersten kleinen donnerstag
ja genau die ersten kleinen
geländegewinne und dann haben wir mal
grafisch vorbereitet was ist seitdem
passiert was ist stand heute morgen
gestern abend passiert und wir sehen ja
vor allem sozusagen geländegewinne im
süden des landes und im norden des
landes also hier dazugekommen jeder zu
bekommen aber es ist eben nicht so dass
die hälfte der ukraine mittlerweile rot
gefärbt jährigen
wladimir putins angriffskrieg trifft die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung in den
städten aktiv und sumi werden
öffentliche gebäude ohne rücksicht auf
verluste bombardiert an diesem sechsten
tag julian da kommt der tod wieder aus
dem himmel wir schauen direkt auf die
aufnahmen und du erklärst uns was genau
wie hier sehen und wie genau hier
gemordet wird ja heute morgen ich muss
sagen ich war schockiert als ich die
fotos gesehen habe ich stand vor diesen
vor diesem haus direkt vor der pandemie
das was wir sehen ist ein einschlag im
regierungsgebäude von krakau genau im
zentrum der stadt wir sehen hier erster
dritter 22 um 81 gab es hier den angriff
weil wir sehen tatsächlich hier auf
diesen aufnahmen wir markieren es einmal
wie diese rakete vom himmel kommt dieses
gebäude trifft unten menschen auf dem
weg zur arbeit menschen die ins büro
kommt vielleicht auf dem weg zur arbeit
auf dem weg zum einkaufen und dann eben
vom himmel diese rakete was was ist das
für ein geschoss
das ist noch nicht hundertprozentig klar
meine analyse deutet darauf hin dass es
sich hier um einigen marschflugkörper
vom typ kaliber handelt wir haben einen
einzigen einschlag gehabt das ist also
kein wie wir gestern gesehen haben
mehrfach raketenwerfer angriff der ein
großes gebiet
bombardiert sondern es ist ein einschlag
ein einzelner einschlag eines einzeln
geschosses wir sehen auch dass relativ
lang ich würde zu schätzen so 56 meter
und auch relativ breit wie breiter als
eine grad rakete und dass wir ein
einzelner einschlag haben und dass eben
übrigens daneben geschossen hat es hat
nicht das gebäude getroffen das hat
direkt davor die passanten getroffen hat
die zivilisten getroffen dass es auf ein
regierungsgebäude trotzdem gerichtet ist
das spricht dafür dass wir hier einen
gezielten angriff mit einem
marschflugkörper haben und dass das ist
die folge springen in das haus ein und
sehen diese absolute zerstören die
fenster raus gesprengt durch die
druckwelle und überall zerstörung und
tod auf der straße und wir wissen
mittlerweile dass es mindestens neun
tote hier gegeben hat die stadt
attraktiv die leidet seit tagen wir
wollen uns eine andere szene angucken
von gestern die den einsatz von
streubomben kommentiert wie ich drück
einfach auf play und du beschreibst also
was genau wir jetzt sehen
ja das ist ja eine großen angriffe
gestern mit streumunition auf die stadt
wir hatten das schon erklärt da werden
also raketen beschossen mehrfach
raketenwerfer die dann in einigen
hundert meter bevor sie das ziel
erreichen viele viele kleine bomben
loslassen zwischen 50 bomben und
teilweise sind sogar 100 punkten kommt
auf die rakete an die dann verteilt
werden und jeder davon ist tödlich also
jede gaben gestern leute gesehen mit
abgerissenen händen mit abgerissenen
füßen so was passiert wenn man wenn man
von so einer bombe getroffen wird warum
sitzt man sowas ein warum sitzt man
sowas gegen zivilisten ein ja vor allem
wir können uns ja man gucken was wir
sehen wir sehen hier einen kindergarten
das ist ein kindergarten ja wir sehen
hier die die rutschen 18 auf meinen sohn
gerne spielt wir sehen hier den
sandkasten und wir sehen hier tote
kinder und erwachsene die also gerade in
die kita reingegangen sind und man sieht
hier wie wie das aussieht also video
gezeigt das ist 123456 einschläge die
jetzt sichtbar sind wenn es zum beispiel
in gebäude reingeht dann sehen was er
von außen nicht aber so setzt putin
seine waffen ein ja gegen schulen und
kindergärten
putin setzt den beschuss von
ukrainischen großstädten ford person im
süden des landes ist die erste
hafenstadt die von putins truppen
eingenommen wird
schauen sie hier ein wohnblock in carson
hier unten da brennt es schon und jetzt
achten sie gleich einmal hier oben ein
ganz normaler wohnblock familienleben wo
menschen leben und dann auf einmal
schlägt dort das nächste geschoss ein
völlig willkürlich trifft es hier leute
gehören die anwohner die das filmen die
angst um ihr leben haben schlägt die
nächste bombe die nächste gerade
vielleicht bei mir ein dass der bittere
der tragische der schreckliche alltag
auch hier noch mal ein video aus cars
sollen wir sehen gleich einen russischen
schützenpanzer ich mag ihn einmal für
sie der kommt hier die straße
hinuntergefahren und geht dann nach hier
oben in stellung und wird gleich quer
durch diesen ort schießen vollkommen
klar wer da in den weg kommt wer da in
der nähe ist der wirt getroffen von dem
von schrotten vom glas von splittern von
schutt und hat am ende keine chance zu
überleben
das ist der alltag so sieht er aus hört
er sich an und so brutal ist ja
mittlerweile für die menschen in der
ukraine
der russische aggressor dringt weiter in
die ukraine ein immer wieder greift die
armee häuser siedlungen an verbreiten so
angst und schrecken unter der
bevölkerung
gut den soldaten haben hier kersten
heute erobert das haben wir gehört eine
ganz wichtige hafenstadt wo man eben
auch aus dem vom wasser aus dann am ende
weitere truppen schicken kann wir sehen
dass also hier unten gebietsgewinne für
die russen zu verbuchen sind von hier
immer mehr und auch hier oben in und um
kharkiv erobern russische soldaten
gebiete und städte oder zerstören sie
einfach in all diesen gebieten da
kämpfen aber nach wie vor natürlich auch
ukrainische soldaten die ich mal in gelb
markiere die erbitterten widerstand
leisten die probieren ihre heimat ihre
familien und ihre kinder zu verteidigen
das hier das ist eine straßenszene hier
noch gut zu sehen dass eben die
ukrainische fahne weht und jetzt richten
sie gleich einmal ihren blick hierhin
hier fährt ein russischer panzer auf und
achten sie darauf wenn man vielleicht
das bild ins vollbild leicht nehmen was
dieser russische panzer macht und wohin
er schießen wird die rakete des panzers
die schlägt nämlich nur wenige meter
unter dem mann der das video hier macht
ein ich zeige ihnen die situation
nochmal urbanes gelände statt links und
rechts leben menschen und der panzer der
nimmt dann das wohnhaus ins visier und
feuer total rein
[Musik]
seit kriegsbeginn schien der sieg der
russischen streitkräfte nur eine frage
der zeit zu sein doch die ukrainer
setzten ihrem gegner schwer zu mit
hochmoderner ausrüstung
wenn wir gemeinsam mit hier auf unseren
monitor schauen dann sehen wir dort
aufnahmen aus der ukraine und vor allem
wenn wir gleich sehen
79 explodiert weil er getroffen wurde
von einer anti panzer rakete die putze
vor ukrainische soldaten abgefeuert
haben das ist das besondere an diesem
konflikt auf der einen seite der
jahrzehntealte panzer und auf der
anderen seite kann man sie mit mir mit
nach unten eine moderne hightech anti
panzer waffe nl a wieso wird sie
abgekürzt und genannt pure hightech ein
einziger abschluss mit dieser waffe der
kostet 40.000 dollar warum weil alles
automatisch passiert von computern
gesteuert wird der schütze der nimmt
sich diese rakete auf die schulter zielt
durch die c sensorik und hab da
übernimmt der computer steuert die
rakete ins ziel und eben in den t 72
panzern
seit fast zwei wochen herrscht krieg in
der ukraine
sowohl russische als auch ukrainische
truppen haben schwere verluste in der
luft und am boden erlitten immer wieder
zeigen bilder wie russische konvois
ungeschützt durch die ukraine fahren das
nutzt die ukrainische armee aus seit
tagen da hören wir dass wladimir putins
truppen in der ukraine
gerade die nachschubkonvois immer wieder
angegriffen und zerstört werden und
julian jetzt liegt uns ein video vor
eine helmkamera von ukrainischen
soldaten die mal zeigt wie genau diese
hinterhalte funktionieren und wie dieser
angriff auf die russischen truppen genau
vonstatten läuft für uns dadurch ganz
genau was wir hier sehen ist ein video
was uns vorgestern abend erreicht hat
ist consol aus der provinz oder aus der
region stammen und was wir hier sind
tatsächlich jetzt sechs soldaten drei
sind zu sehen eine kamera auf zwei
hinter ihm die einen russischen panzer
angreifen wir sehen das jetzt hier
gerade eine rpg geschossen wird also
eine panzerfaust ausgeschossen wird eine
ganz alte jetzt sehen wir auch die die
zurückgeblieben sind und am ende wird
dieser panzer dann zerstört und die
ukraine an diese kleine schlacht obwohl
sie nur zu sechst sind hier gewonnen
nach diesen niederlagen setzte mir putin
nun auf kampferprobte hilfe aus
tschetschenien gehören die ganze tage
schon von diesen männern einmal von dir
die analyse wer wer ist das hier und
warum sind diese männer so gefährlich
also was wir hier haben sind
spezialeinheiten des tschetschenen
machthabers manche sachen yakin ist man
teil von russland aktuell kadyrow und
das sind seine leute das sind die
spezialeinheiten aus tschetschenien und
du hast du schon gesagt die gehören zu
den brutalsten zu den gnadenlosen aber
auch zu den effektivsten einheiten der
russischen armee dann das sind leute die
quasi immer kampferfahrung haben die
also auch im süden gegen gegen
aufständische kämpfen die sind nördlich
von kiew sind wirklich die besten
einheiten die sie haben und die sollen
wohl den den angriff auch auf tiere oder
die umzingelung von kiew aktuell leiten
ein exklusives video zeigt die
zerstörung eines russischen
flugabwehrgeschütze bild analysiert die
aufnahme und die ukrainische
angriffsstrategie mit der neuen
waffenlieferungen aus deutschland
dieses video ist sozusagen die aufnahme
aus der aus der drohne aus dem fall
einer türkischen bayraktar tb 2 tone wir
sehen es jetzt der explosion hat dieses
luftabwehrsystem sehr effektiv bekämpft
diese beinahe ktw zwei drohnen
haben die türkischen staat die typische
rüstungsindustrie auch schon verkauft
oder beziehungsweise wurde von
tierischen unterstützen einheiten
eingesetzt in syrien im familien- bzw
aserbaidschan und in libyen und haben
wir auch schon mit großem erfolg
russische luftabwehrsysteme man es hier
s1 bekämpft und jetzt sind sie auch in
der ukraine aktiv also mindestens sechs
stück hat mindestens sechs bei atv 2 hat
hat die ukrainische armee bereits
bekommen es ist anzunehmen dass da am
markt weitere folgen werden ein
ukrainischer soldat der da
eine anti panzer waffe auf dem rücken
hat und was genau werden ist das für
eine panzer waffe ich probier's mal zu
markieren was sehen wir hier
ich weiß nicht einmal die beschriftung
erkennen kann aber dass es handelt sich
tatsächlich um ein deutsches modell das
ganze haus 3
deutschland hat ja angekündigt 1000
panzer und waffen zu liefern an die
ukraine und mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
sehen wir dann da eines dieser modelle
die dort beliefert worden was wir
erfolgreich ist diese waffe auch im
vergleich zu den anderen modellen die
wir in den letzten tagen gesehen haben
die ja sehr effektiv konvois der russen
ausgeschaltet haben wo steht da die
deutsche waffe ist sie eher veraltet
oder eher modern
also ich glaube das kommt immer darauf
an auf den jeweiligen einsatzbereiche
kurz kürzere distanzen ist sie durchaus
effektiv die wurde ja vorher auch schon
mal exportiert werden uns an den
konflikt im nordirak als als die
bundeswehr dann merke der spengler
milizen geschult hat daneben unter
anderem auch der war ganz nah fast 3
allerdings natürlich gelenkte
panzerabwehrhandwaffen sowie
sowie diese britische ändern oder oder
die amerikanische fdp 148 nochmal
deutlich effektiver weise höhere
reichweiten haben weil sich
selbstständig gezielt suchen und
sozusagen auch es einfacher ist damit
bewegliche ziele zu bekämpfen allerdings
wird das gar nicht kleinreden das
natürlich trotzdem auf kürzere des
gefechts distanzen durchaus eine sehr
effektive waffe
putin ordnet den angriff auf die
hafenstadt mario pohl an dabei sterben
mindestens drei menschen 17 werden
verletzt in unserem lagezentrum da
probieren wir ihnen seit tagen diesen
russischen angriffskrieg ein stück weit
zu erklären wenn man das überhaupt kann
aber julian es gibt daneben auch momente
und bilder die uns beide ein stückweit
sprachlos zurücklassen muss man sagen
wie das was uns aus mario pohl erreicht
ja ganz genau wir hatten es gerade eben
schon gehört es gab gestern nachmittag
diesen unglaublichen angriff auf eine
geburtsklinik in mario pohl auf ein
krankenhaus in dem zu diesem zeitpunkt
frauen mit ihren männern natürlich waren
kinderkriegen wollten und diese klinik
wurde gestern angegriffen wahnsinn
sowohl vorher als auch nachher hat
russland diesen angriff bestätigt und
verteidigt ihn und julian es gibt ein
video was diesen moment kurz nach dem
angriff zeigt was sehen wir hier ganz
genau wir sind also die klinik quasi im
innenhof der klinik die ist so in u form
aufgebaut überall außen rum sind die
sind die gebäude
und wir sehen den wirklich moment nach
dem angriff wir sehen also die völlige
zerstörung hier im hof wir sehen dort
wie die väter also die eher männer mit
den ehefrauen und den schwangeren
ehefrauen herauskommen wie die abgeführt
oder wieder aus dem gebäude geführt
werden
und der grund dass sie überhaupt noch
leben ist das wir sehen es vielleicht
auch aus verschiedenen perspektiven ist
dass die russische bombe nicht genau die
häuser getroffen hat sondern die ist
imhof explodiert hat also die ganzen
dort die ganzen fahrzeuge zerstört wir
sehen und dass das unfassbar dass von
diesem angriff so weit wir wissen das
ist ein niveau zu sagen fünf meter
tiefer krater der dort gerissen wurde
und
das ist der einzige grund weshalb wir
schwer verletzte vielleicht teilweise
auch sterbende frauen schwangere dort
sehen aber zumindest
keiner kann ich möchte keine noch
schlimmeren bilder dort gesehen haben
wir wollen trotzdem verstehen kann man
ist nicht aber vielleicht versuchen zu
erklären warum diese stadt mariupol
gerade so im mittelpunkt steht einmal
natürlich der grund mario pohl ist die
letzte stadt die putin noch im wege
steht um einen landkorridor zwischen der
krim und dem russischen festland zu
schaffen die krim hat er 2014 der
ukraine gestohlen hat eine brücke gebaut
aber das reicht ihm nicht er will einen
festland korridor haben der solchen land
gehen und wir sehen erst eingerichtet
nur mario pohl steht ja noch im wege der
zweite grund mario pohl ist natürlich
ein wirtschaftszentrum das wichtigste
wirtschaftszentrum an am asowschen
meeres oft schon mehr ist dieses kleine
mehr neben dem schwarzen meer was man
hier zeigen kann auch das war putin die
letzten jahre ein dorn im auge wir
erinnern uns dass er die brücke öfter
gesperrt hat das kampfflugzeug geflogen
sind er möchte also unbedingt das haben
und der dritte und letzte grund ist dass
mario pohl 2014 bereits von putins
schergen von den sogenannten
prorussischen separatisten die
separatisten waren sondern immer von
moskau gelenkt waren wurde 2014 schon
kurzzeitig eingenommen bei einige monate
unter kontrolle die wurden dann
zurückgeschlagen von von ukrainischen
verbänden und seitdem sagen diese diese
volksrepublik donetzk sogenannte auch
wie gesagt alles camel marionetten sagen
wir wollen mario pohl haben das ist eine
wichtige stadt für uns
gut ausgerüstet unter anderem mit
deutschen waffen verteidigen ukrainische
truppen weiter irland putins soldaten
geraten auf dem weg nach kiew immer
wieder unter beschuss ein vorort von
kiew hier ist ein kamerateam das
begleitet eine ukrainische einheit man
hört den gefechtslärm gleich und vor
allem sieht man eben die da ja umgekehrt
in den vororten geschossen wird wir
haben dieses video ausgewählt und nicht
wegen dieser kampfhandlung sondern was
uns hier vor allem was zählt ist die
waffenauswahl denn die soldaten die hier
für die ukraine im einsatz sind wir
haben ja so einen ganzen europäischen
gemischtwarenladen an modernen waffen
dabei wir haben diesmal vorbereitet was
die da alles dabei was inters für waffen
was wir hier sehen ist das was wir
tatsächlich auch erwartet haben wir
haben also auf der andere seite diese
riesige russische panzer armee mit
tausenden fahrzeugen dem hat die ukraine
und auch sonst fast niemand etwas
entgegen zu bieten auf der anderen seite
sehen wir hier ukrainische einheiten
kleiner einheiten schnelle einheiten die
sich mobil von einem ort zum anderen
bewegen und die waffen die die haben
sind tatsächlich best of the best gegen
panzer gepanzerte fahrzeuge zum einen
kann es im vorstand die apg 7 das ist
ein altes sowjetisches modell aber
weiterhin sehr effektiv das hat
überhaupt da muss man wirklich genau
zielen quasi und dann auf dem panzer
schießen aber wir sehen hier unten die
ende aus großbritannien wir sehen die 10
90 aus spanien mund und das ärgert
einige in russland ganz besonders wir
sind die panzerfaust drei aus
deutschland das heißt auch die deutschen
panzerabwehrwaffen von den 4000
geschrieben wurden außensteckdosen 100
aus holland genau ganz genau sind
mittlerweile nicht nur in lemberg
angekommen sondern sind in und um kiew
angekommen wie sehen sie hier auf dem
rücken des soldaten und werden dort eben
gegen russische einheiten eingesetzt was
wir auch vorbereitet haben julian ist
ein ja dramatisches spektakuläres
drohnen feet aus der ukraine ich spüre
ein stück weit vor und du erklärst uns
was wir hier gleich sehen werden ab
sekunde 20 erkennt man sehr genau was
hier gleich alles passiert ja was wir
hier sehen ist einer der russischen
panzer vorstöße in richtung hauptstadt
kiew wir befinden uns hier an der grenze
des vorortes pro war etwa zehn kilometer
zur grenze von 4 23 meter zum zentrum
und käfer das eine riesige stadt und wir
sehen diesen panzer konvoi der und das
muss man wieder sagen verwundert uns wie
schon so oft die hauptstraße nimmt weder
von links noch von rechts abgesichert
ist kein luftüberwachung hat wir sehen
hier oben dass eine ukrainische drohne
die das filmt und der cs gleichen hier
oben geht schon los von ukrainischer
artillerie angegriffen wird die panzer
die stehen unglaublich eng das haben wir
immer wieder gesagt wie merkwürdig diese
fahrzeuge geparkt sind dass man
eigentlich nicht so eng man sieht ja
auch das kreuz und quer geparkt wird man
sich auch womöglich gegenseitig
blockiert gleich denn julian hat schon
gesagt hier unten sieht man bereits den
ersten einschlag ganz klassisch auch für
seinen angriff man trifft erst das erste
fahrzeug und gleich werden wir noch
sehen dass die zweite rakete hier hinten
einschlägt und dann ist dieser konvoi
ein stückweit sozusagen ausgeliefert wir
sehen dass also hier unten der erste
treffer dann oben der zweite treffer und
dann wird in diesem konvoi weiter
reingeschossen und die fahrzeuge ja die
stehen da und können eigentlich nicht
viel machen und am ende flüchten sie
wieder am ende verlassen hier in
südlicher richtung von hier aus belgrad
kiew gewesen sie für je nach norden
wieder zurück ziehen sich zurück das ist
wirklich kaum zu glauben das ist eine
absolute übermacht hier also wirklich
eine extreme übermacht an soldaten am
material die aber weil sie eben in einen
hinterhalt sich ohne not offenbar
bewegen und dort dezimiert werden wir
wissen dass der kommandant dieser
einheit gestorben ist bei diesem angriff
der wohl zwischen den panzern sich
bewegt hat wurden sie dann
zurückgeschlagen und haben diesen oft
bovary wieder in richtung
nordosten verlassen
seit drei wochen führt wladimir putin
einen erbarmungslosen krieg gegen die
ukraine lässt immer wieder städte aus
der luft bombardieren kiew ist weiter
schwer umkämpft doch die ukraine geben
ihre hauptstadt nicht widerstandslos auf
die ganze welt schaut auf diese
ukrainische hauptstadt im norden des
landes
denn die russen die wollen hier fördern
um den präsidenten dort zu stürzen zu
verhaften vielleicht sogar zu ermorden
um einen präsidenten zu installieren der
in ihrem interesse handelt ein
marionetten präsident es kommt eben
nicht nur auf die waffen an es kommt
natürlich auch auf den ort an und wie
ich diesen ort vorbereite also die stadt
die vor mir liegt hinter mir die käfig
diese stadt verteidige und wie ich das
genau vorbereitet wie man das am besten
macht die stadt vorbereiten das zeigen
wir ihnen jetzt denn das a und o dafür
dass ist das blockieren von straßen zum
beispiel indem ich alte lkws müllautos
busse voll mit schrott und schublade und
so strasen versperre da kommt dann eben
kein panzer mehr durch oder auch ganz
klassisch panzersperren wie wir sie seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg kennen und die
eben den weg versperren warum macht man
das einmal den angriff abbremsen führt
dazu dass ganze konvois und colón in den
stau kommen abbremsen der motor läuft ab
weiter sie verbrauchen weiter benzin und
wir wissen die russen sie haben in
diesem krieg große nachschubprobleme und
das andere ist natürlich abbremsen und
den verkehr den panzer dahin lenken wo
ich ihn treffen kann das wollen wir
ihnen jetzt zeigen denn hier haben wir
eine straße vorbereitet und in diese
straße da wird gleich ein panzer rollen
und dann werden sie genau sehen was
passiert wenn dieser panzer am ende in
so eine s kurve kommt denn hier haben
die verteidiger einen checkpoint
angelegt und das zwingt den panzer dazu
langsam zu fahren und sehen das seitlich
zu fahren seitlich ist für die
verteidiger ganz wichtig denn der panzer
der ist an der seite besonders
verwundbar wenn ich hier und sie sehen
dass links der mann der hat bereits eine
panzerabwehrrakete wenn der den panzer
jetzt angriff von der seite dann ist der
panzer da eben besonders verwundbar und
auch das eine szene die wir in der
ukraine immer wieder erleben von dächern
aus von hochpunkten aus werden gegner
eben bekämpft werden die russischen
angreifer bekämpft denn natürlich höher
ist immer ein vorteil in diesem krieg es
braucht den richtigen waffen missbraucht
die richtige planung für den ort des
gefechts und es braucht am ende eine
starke verteidigung rückzugsorte an die
ich mich sicher zurückziehen kann und
wenn die ukraine all das tun dann können
sie am ende den krieg die schlacht um
ihre hauptstadt kiew gewinnen und damit
womöglich auch den krieg gegen die
russen überhaupt geben
wie rücksichtslos die russische armee
bei der eroberung kiews vorgeht zeigen
diese bilder eines einkaufszentrums nach
einem raketenangriff sind von dem
gebäudekomplex im nordwesten der stadt
nur noch die verkohlten überreste übrig
bei dem angriff starben mindestens acht
menschen
doch putins drucken richten ihre raketen
nicht nur aufgehen
auch mario pohl im süden des landes
steht im mittelpunkt der gefechte die
hafenstadt ist für russland von großer
strategischer bedeutung
wie grausam dort gewütet wird zeigt bild
militärexperte julian ripke
wir sehen hier den einsatz
eines so genannten fonds 1a das ist ein
raketenwerfer der russischen armee der
mit die schwersten raketen wirft und vor
allem sogenannte thermo bayerische
waffen wirft thermo bayerischer raketen
sind solche raketen die also nicht
einfach nur explodieren sondern auch
noch während ihres anschlags der luft
außenrum den gesamten sauerstoff
entziehen damit ein unterdruck erzeugen
und interessant ist eben auch zu sehen
dieses set hier bei dem z kann man noch
mal sehen was das einheiten sind die im
süden der ukraine vorstoßen und dass es
ihm tatsächlich eine einheit ist die
dort agiert hier unten 7 als auch
nochmal wir wollen uns mal ansehen was
diese waffen und andere waffen die auch
mario pohl eingesetzt werden für
zerstörung anrichten klar ist man kann
damit nicht eindeutig militärische ziele
bekämpfen sondern man kann nur im großen
raum im großen rahmen alles zerstören
was sich bewegt hier sehen wir als
allererstes ein einkaufszentrum in mario
pohl eine drohen ansicht einer drohne
fliegt hier über wir sehen das
einkaufszentrum ist völlig zerstört
das heißt nicht nur in kiew den
einkaufszentren beschlossen sondern auch
in mario pohl wären diese beschossen wir
wollen aber noch mal weiter ging das
hier sind hochhäuser das sind wirklich
10 12 gestellte hochhäuser die völlig
zerstört sind und als allerletzte sehen
wir gleich mal wie was für eine macht
diese raketen tatsächlich haben sich im
gerade gezeigt habe ich hatte mal kurz
hier dass das video an wir sehen hier in
einem zehnstöckigen haus ein riesiges
loch drin das heißt wir haben jetzt zehn
stockwerke die auf einmal eingestürzt
sind nach dem einschlag einer rakete wir
gehen nochmal einmal ins land hinaus aus
dem mario pohl hinaus und zwar in die
region cerny hier oben von dort hat ein
neues video erreicht wo man noch mal
sieht warum die russen dann so schwer
voran kommen und warum es für die russen
so unglaublich kostspielig ist auch an
menschenleben kostet ist man geht davon
aus dass bislang zwischen 10.000 und 14
tausend russische soldaten in der
ukraine gestorben sind und 26 tagen wir
gucken uns das noch mal an erstmal
drohen aufnahmen eines eines angriffs
hier auf einen russischen konvoi und wir
sehen dann gleich wie die ukraine
sozusagen hier wie die op nach feiern
dass sie diesen diesen kontrolle
übernommen haben das hier ist einer der
haupt kampfpanzer auch der ist zerstört
wurden wir sehen hier vorne da hat
jemand auf die ketten gezielt diesen
kaputt aber auch weitere weitere bilder
zeigen ganz klar dass dieser konvoi der
sich durchs land bewegt hat der
wahrscheinlich zu einer großen stadt
wollte hier von ukrainischen einheiten
zerstört wurde das gleiche bild wie wir
schon oft gesehen haben wir haben die
schweren panzer die schweren fahrzeuge
der russen auf der anderen seite zu fuß
die ukrainer die ihr land kommen die
nicht mal eine fahrzeuge haben die aber
eben entscheidende panzerbrechende
waffen haben viele davon aus deutschland
die panzerfaust 3 und andere aus anderen
europäischen und nordamerikanischen
ländern und hier sehr erfolgreich sind
am ende wird dann natürlich mal die
munition mitgenommen dass man möchte
nicht nur man möchte nicht nur sozusagen
diesem konvoi hier oder hat nicht nur
ihn besiegt sondern hat auch gleich
munition das sind soweit ich das hier
gerade raketen um danach wiederum
weitere attacken zu starten
tag für tag verteidigt sich die
ukrainische armee entschlossen gegen
russland doch den kampf um mario pohl
scheint die ukraine zu verlieren diese
drohnen aufnahmen zeigen das ausmaß der
zerstörungen in der hafenstadt ras lanuf
hätten zwischen bis zu 90 prozent der
gebäude dem erdboden gleichgemacht
putins truppen wollen mario pohl
komplett und ohne rücksicht auf zivile
opfer einnehmen
wer kämpft dort eigentlich mario wir
wissen auf der einen seite ist es die
ukrainische sind ukrainische
marineinfanteristen und die
nationalgarde regimentes oft ist das
ganz genau dieses staates halten auf der
anderen seite sind es teilweise die
sogenannten kämpfer der volksrepublik
tornetz teilweise auch russischer
soldaten aber und das ist ganz wichtig
viele von denen sind auch aus dem
kaukasus dort hingereist hier sehen wir
von herrn kadyrow von ramzan kadyrov dem
tschetschenen führer selbst gepostet
eine tschetschenische spezialeinheit die
also hier in mario kämpft hier sehen wir
truppen aus dem kaukasus und zwar aus
dagestan das ist die nachbarrepublik von
tschetschenien die für einen freudentanz
auf in der in der tradition in der
islamischen tradition ihrer ihrer
heimatregion was ich ganz spannend finde
dass wir diese weste sehen die der mann
an hat london eine spezialeinheit des
russischen innenministeriums
bekannt sozusagen als prügel einheit im
land die immer dann rein geht wenn die
polizei nicht mehr klarkommt die aber in
dem fall jetzt auch militärische
aufgaben übernimmt
soviel zur lage in mario pohl ich
versuche noch einmal weiter zu gehen und
zwar wieder auf die strategie der
ukrainer uns uns zu konzentrieren ein
interessantes video hat uns erreicht von
einer organischen einheit
das zeigt ich glaube dass man ganz kurz
hier vorne einen russischen konvoi der
fährt also sozusagen von hier links nach
rechts fährt hier weiter und gleich
sehen wir eine explosion die dort
stattfindet und diese explosion aber wir
gucken uns das einmal an hat sehr eigene
charakteristik und zwar jetzt passiert
sie tipps was hier eingesetzt wurde ist
nicht etwa eine panzerfaust ist nicht
einfach ein panzer oder so etwas sondern
es ist eine spring schlauch einen
schlauch den man irgendwo in einem
gebiet rhein
einschließt oder liegt das vermint ist
und dann springt man diesen schlauch und
hofft dass alle minen explodieren wenn
man genau guckt es unterhalten 30-40
explosionen sie finden dort statt
parallel zu dem konvoi also klassische
partizan taktik wirklich die klassische
geriet taktik der ukraine die alles
nimmt was sie findet um ebendiese
russischen konvois zu sprengen und wir
sehen jetzt einmal noch wie es danach
aussieht die aufnahmen sind von gestern
abend hier sehen wir dieser konvoi oder
ein konto auch in der gleichen region
von gleichen einheit angegriffen hier
vorne ein sogenanntes btr 80 also ein
russisches ein schützenpanzer da hinten
brennt ein weiteres fahrzeug das ist es
wie dieser wie dieser konvoi sozusagen
danach aussah
während mario pohl im süden des landes
einer trümmerlandschaft gleicht kommt
die russische bodenoffensive in
nördlichen teilen des landes nur langsam
voran die ukraine schützen die
hauptstadt kiew vor weiteren angriffen
die armee hat sich wichtige vororte
gesichert diese zurückgewonnenen gebiete
sind für die ukrainischen truppen
strategisch wichtig tatsächlich gibt es
in den letzten tagen erstmals positive
zeichen erstmals zurück eroberungen der
ukrainer in den vororten von kiew und
das wollen wir es jetzt mal angucken
erst kurz auf der karte in horst hummel
das ist hier oben dieser
militärflugplatz sind die russen am
ersten tag des krieges gelandet das
heißt dort in diesem flugplatz in hand
hier erobert da haben sie diese luft
lande operation gestartet und den setzen
sie seitdem und von dort aus und das
haben die versucht wollten sie kiew
erobern sie wollten also immer weiter
vordringen wollten dann sozusagen die
stadt einnehmen über einige weitere
vororte aber wir sehen bis heute sind
sie kaum weiter vorangekommen im
gegenteil die ukrainer demokraten ist es
gelungen in den letzten tagen immer mehr
vororte von kiew zurück zu erobern
beispielsweise im team sehen wir jetzt
hier an der front das war fast komplett
erobert von den russen das ist teilweise
wieder in ukrainischer hand wischt sehen
wir hier im norden auch dort haben die
russen gestanden ist wieder ein
ukrainischer hand pro vary dort gab es
im westen der stadt im osten der stadt
schwere kämpfe dort gibt es aktuell auch
keine kämpfe mehr weil eben die ukraine
zurückerobert haben 50 kilometer
westlich der stadt in der stadt mag.a
rief die wurde gestern zurück vorgestern
zurückerobert von ukrainischen kräften
das ist extrem wichtig denn dort haben
wir tatsächlich eine gegenoffensive aus
der west ukraine zum ersten mal also
dass sich westukrainische truppen
hierdurch kämpfen in richtung hauptstadt
und versuchen diese strategisch wichtige
autobahn die führt nach quito nur etwa
hundert kilometer weiter westlich
zurückzuerobern noch ist die teilweise
in russischer hand aber dort gibt es
eine gegenoffensive eben aus westen zum
ersten mal nicht aus der hauptstadt und
man versucht dort das ganze
zurückzuerobern wie sieht das vor ort
aus also wie sieht das aus wenn dort
gekämpft wird das wollen wir uns jetzt
einfach mal angucken in einem vorort
hier wird um eine bahnstation gekämpft
das heißt hier haben wir eine einheit
und zwar etwas ganz besonderes eine
eine muslimische eine teilweise aus
tschetschenischen freiwilligen
bestehende einheit die hiergegen putins
truppen kennt auf seiten der ukraine wir
haben verschiedene leute gesagt die ja
die kämpfen wie die löwen wurde gesagt
weil sie eben sozusagen noch eine
rechnung offen haben mit putin aus
tschetschenien aus den kriegen die er
dort geführt hat er dort erfolgreich
aufgeführt hat wir sehen also hier
sozusagen wie das abgeht wie links und
rechts von einem bahnübergang und einem
bahnhof dort gekämpft wird auf der
anderen seite eben die russischen
truppen
diese szene spielt sich einige kilometer
östlich von tiere aber ähnliche szenen
spielen sich auch im norden und im osten
der westen der hauptstadt ab
das sieht jetzt ganz erstmal ein
bisschen unorganisiert aus man denkt ja
was machen die da die schießen da wird
um dich rum aber das ist es nicht die
ukraine haben eine ganz wichtige
strategie sie überwachen alle ihre
angriffe mit drohnen das heißt wenn sie
irgendwo vorrücken wenn sie die russen
angreifen wir sehen uns hier dann machen
sie das nicht einfach so sondern guckt
nicht immer genau erst an wo sind die
russischen truppen von wo müssen wir sie
angreifen wo es ihre schwachstelle und
was wir hier sehen das ist ein
eingegrabene russischer schützenpanzer
der steht dort neben einem zivilen haus
verstehen verschanzt sich dort und kurz
darauf sehen wir das von rechts ihnen
etwas trifft
nämlich jetzt das soll eine jahr will
ihn rakete seien eine der westlichen
raketen werden eben doch die panzerfaust
3 im video gesehen aus deutschland das
ist eine amerikanische rakete die hier
genutzt wurde die trifft diesen
schützenpanzer der geht in flammen auf
und danach wird die position im
angegriffen von ukrainischen truppen zum
schluss noch mal auf die karte die
situation ist sehr kompliziert wir haben
teile der ukraine wo auch zu recht diese
dieser optimismus herrscht dass die
russen nicht weiter vordringen werden
auch ich kann mir von dem was ich dir
nicht vorstellen dass in den nächsten
jahren irgendwann kiew eingenommen wird
von russischen truppen auf der anderen
seite haben wir leider muss man sagen im
osten sehr starke russische
geländegewinne eben in diesem
strategisch wichtigen gebiet zwischen
der besetzten krim und dem russischen
festland auf der einen seite was putin
schon immer als ein korridor haben
wollte und auf der anderen seite
rundherum um die sogenannten
volksrepublik die marionettenregime auch
dort rückt die russische armee vor
der krieg in der ukraine
er scheint noch lange nicht vorbei zu
sein wladimir putin lässt seine truppen
im land weiterhin grausam zerstören und
morgen die humanitäre lage vor ort
verschlimmert sich mit jedem tag
millionen- ukraine sind bereits geflohen
vor allem frauen und kinder verlassen
das land während ihre ehemänner und
väter bleiben und die heimat beschützen
bild informiert sie weiterhin über die
lage in der ukraine
mit unseren analysen grafiken und
expertengesprächen erklären wir ihnen
immer aktuell was vor ort geschieht
[Musik]